Everything has been nice and rectangular so far. We've modified both the
polygon and texture coordinates, but in such a way that these both always
formed some rectangle. Now it's time to see what happens when this
correspondence is broken. In this new demo, we can move the locations and
change the positions and u v's of the two upper corners. Let's start by
modifying the position of the upper right corner. You can see how this distorts
the texture. Now let's change the u v coordinates. This also distorts the
texture, but in an inverted way. For example, as we make v larger, the texture
distorts in a manner similar to what we saw before. An increase of v instead of
a decrease in the y coordinate causes this distortion. Try the demo yourself,
and see what various changes do. When you're done, I'll ask you a question
about what you saw.